Hello, I’m Craig and this is Crash Course
Government and Politics and today I’m going
to talk a bit more about economic policy.
Ran into the table there a little bit. Whoo!
Economic policy can be dangerous.
Specifically, we’re going to look at some
of the broad goals of economic policy and
some of the things that the government does
to try to accomplish those goals.
And we may even provide some examples of times
when the government DID accomplish them, so
take that, skeptics. But, I have to admit,
a lot of the time the goals are just goals.
[Theme Music]
So all people have goals and aspirations (except
me) and the government, since it’s made
up of people is no different. Well I do have one goal:
to punch the eagle again. And I did it. Accomplished.
Well, actually the government's different
because it’s economic goals are much bigger
and more important than, say my goal of punching
the eagle again. Although I would argue my
goal is pretty important. So what are these,
goals of economic policy?
The first goal is promoting stable markets.
We talked about how the government structures
the market system in the last episode,
so I probably don’t need to repeat it.
At least I hope I don’t. You should’ve been
paying attention.
But since nobody wants a malfunctioning market,
most of the things the government does to
create a market system also work to make the
system stable and predictable.
Maintaining law and order and minimizing monopolies
are examples of government actions that make
the market system stable. I didn’t know the government
maintained Law and Order – oh not the tv show, OK.
One of the more interesting ways – ok interesting
to me – that the government keeps markets
predictable is through national regulations
of things like automobile fuel efficiency standards.
If there were no national regulations, and
states were allowed to set the rules, then
it might be possible for car makers in Detroit
to build cars that live up to the mileage
standards in Michigan, but not in California,
and that would be anarchy.
Well, maybe not anarchy exactly, but it wouldn’t
be good, and it’d make it much more difficult
for manufacturers to know what kind of cars
to make. Also, do you really want California,
the state with the biggest population, making
rules for the rest of us? Of course you don’t.
The second major goal of economic policy is
promoting economic prosperity. Here’s another
example of a situation where many people will tell
you that the best way for the government to promote
prosperity is to get out of the way, and they may
have a point, but the government doesn’t stop trying.
So what does the government do to promote
prosperity? For one thing, it tries to keep
a positive investment climate and build
confidence in the economy.
One way the federal government can accomplish
this is through regulating financial markets
through the Securities and Exchange Commission
since people won’t want to invest in the
securities markets if they think the game's
fixed.
Another thing the government can do, if it’s
feeling particularly Keynesian, is to spend
money on public investment in things like
highways and the internet. While not actually
built by Al Gore, it did begin with a government
program out of the Defense Department.
The government also pays for research through
the National Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation, and enhances
the workforce through education policy and
immigration policy, all of which contribute
to national prosperity.
Another, and by no means the last, way that
the government can try to make the country
more prosperous is by keeping inflation low.
You can find out more about inflation from
Crash Course: Economics, but the main tool
the government uses to control inflation is
the Federal Reserve, which is so complicated
that it gets it’s own episode.
A third goal of government economic policy, one
closely related to the first two, is promoting business development.
Many people would probably argue that promoting
business development and promoting prosperity
are the same thing but policies aimed at helping
businesses are slightly different and more
focused than those targeting the broader goal
of promoting prosperity.
The main ways that the federal government
promotes business development are through
tariffs and subsidies. Since the Great Depression,
the U.S. has pretty much pursued a policy
of free trade, which means lowering tariffs
on most things, which by forcing them to compete
can hurt businesses, at least in the short
run.
In the past, however, high tariffs allowed
American businesses to develop free from foreign
competition and this helped to make the U.S.
the most powerful industrial nation in the world!
Can we use that Libertage from US History?
I think Yes!
[Libertage]
Subsidies are very controversial and they
come in two forms. Grants in aid for things
like transportation – building those superhighways
again – provide an indirect subsidy to businesses
who don’t have to pay for the roads they
use to ship the goods they make.
Most people don’t complain about this type of subsidy,
because they can also be looked at as a public good.
Direct subsidies are another issue. These
include direct assistance to businesses through
the Small Business Administration and government
investment in firms like Sematech and, more
recently and more controversially, Solyndra.
Many people don’t think that the government
should be in the business of investing in
business and that these subsidies provide the
businesses that receive them with an unfair advantage.
Farm subsidies are probably just as controversial.
They were put in place to help farmers during
The Great Depression, but these days, critics worry
that most of the subsidies go to corporate farms.
The fourth goal of government economic policy
is to protect consumers and employees. A lot
of people will tell you that the federal government
doesn’t do much to protect employees these
days, and those people are probably right,
but in the past it certainly did.
The government made unionization easier with
the National Labor Relations Act and setting
labor standards, especially overtime
rules with the Fair Labor Standards Act.
Both of these were passed in the 1930s, by the way.
Probably the most notable thing that the government
does to protect workers these days is set
the federal minimum wage, but since that topic
is being hotly debated as this episode is
being produced in 2015, I can’t really comment
on how it’s going to turn out.
On the other hand the Occupational Safety
and Health Administration does set up regulations
to prevent workers from breathing in hazardous
fumes and protect them from other potentially
life threatening workplace conditions, and
that’s a good thing.
As far as consumers are concerned, there are
thousands of regulations that protect us to
make sure that the things we buy don’t kill
or maim us. The Food and Drug Administration
makes sure that our medicines aren’t poison,
and the Department of Agriculture inspects
meat, which I think is really good a idea,
actually.
The National Traffic and Motor Vehicle Safety
Act of 1966 made cars safer, and the Consumer
Products Safety Commission helps keep lead
paint out of our toys and saves us from exploding
toasters. I like explosions as much as the
next guy, but not with breakfast.
All of these goals of economic policy, promoting stable
markets, promoting economic prosperity, fostering
business development and protecting employees
and consumers are interrelated and important.
I’ll leave it up to you to decide if one
is more important than the other three, because
that makes for excellent dinner conversation.
If your dinner parties are mostly about the
role the government plays in our economy.
Please invite me to those dinner parties.
I’m hungry, for roast beef and political
debate.
So, to shift gears a little, let’s talk
history, and how the government’s role in
regulating the economy has changed in the
last 240 years or so.
So you probably remember from back when we
talked about the transition from congressional
to presidential government that began with
Teddy Roosevelt and really came into its own
with Franklin Roosevelt, that before the 20th century
the federal government didn’t really do that much.
A lot of that has to do with fiscal policy
and taxation, which we’re going to discuss
in another episode, and maybe that dinner
you’re going to invite me to, but some of
it was certainly because of the way that the Supreme
Court had interpreted the Commerce Clause
to mean that government regulation was suspect,
and by suspect, I mean generally not allowed.
But by the end of the 19th century the Federal
government’s regulatory power had begun
to change, and a lot of that has to do with
one of my favorite subjects - no not Star Wars.
And no not the protection of endangered species.
(punches eagle)
I’m talking about railroads (Yeah!).
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
So, with the completion of the transcontinental
railroad in 1869, travel and communication across
the U.S. became much easier and it was possible
for the first time to have a national market for goods.
If you raised cattle in Kansas, you could now
easily ship beef to New York or San Francisco.
Railroads were, almost by definition, interstate
entities, so it was pretty clear that Congress
could regulate them. And they needed regulation
because railroads had a nasty habit of discriminatory
pricing, charging much, much more for some
shippers than for others. Something had to
be done and Congress stepped in with the Interstate
Commerce Act in 1887, which created the
Interstate Commerce Commission
to regulate railroads.
The period of time around the turn of the
20th century in the U.S. is known as the Gilded
Age and is associated with runaway capitalism
and the creation of modern corporate structures
and industrial capitalists like Andrew Carnegie
– or Carnegie, if you will – and John
D. Rockefeller who are heroes to some and
villains to others. In response to some of
the abuses of the Gilded Age, Congress passed
its first wave of regulatory legislation.
In addition to the ICC, Congress created the
Federal Trade Commission to regulate trade
and the Sherman and Clayton Acts to try to
counter the problem of monopolies. These anti-trust
laws are the basis of modern anti-trust regulation and
have been used against Standard Oil and Microsoft.
This first wave of economic regulation didn’t
have huge effects on the economy, certainly
not greater than the effects of, say World
War I. In the 1920s the federal government
returned to a more traditional laissez faire
approach, which lasted until the Great Depression
swept Herbert Hoover and the Republicans out
of office and Franklin Roosevelt into it.
And with Franklin Roosevelt came the New Deal
and the advent of what law schools sometimes
like to call the administrative and regulatory
state.
Thanks Thought Bubble. We’re not going to
get into details about the various laws and
regulations of the New Deal here, but luckily I think
John talked about them in Crash Course: U.S. History.
John, he talks about stuff.
But in general, those regulations meant that
the federal government would take an active
role in regulating certain sectors of the
economy, like agriculture and transportation.
Sometimes technology played a part. There
really wasn’t a need for a Federal Aviation
Administration until there were airplanes.
The next big wave of government regulation happened
in the early 1970s under, of all people, president Nixon.
These new regulatory laws were different from
their New Deal predecessors in that they focused
on the economy as a whole. For example the
Occupational Safety and Health Administration
dealt with ALL occupations, or at least most
of them, and the EPA was created to protect
the whole country’s environment.
Beginning in the 1980s with Ronald Reagan,
or actually before him under Carter, the federal
government has undertaken various initiatives
to de-regulate the economy, but we already
talked about deregulation in our episode on taming
the bureaucracy so we don’t need to re-hash that here.
The point to remember is that, despite attempts
at deregulation, the administrative regulatory
state appears to be here to stay.
So why do we have an administrative regulatory
state now, even though so many people complain
about it? Part of the reason has to do with
the remarkable staying power of bureaucracies,
which are harder to kill than Wolverine.
Nowadays the federal government not only has
economic goals, goals like increasing prosperity
that most of us agree upon, it also has a
sense, maybe even a belief that it should
try to achieve those goals.
This is a long way from the view of the federal
government that persisted through the 19th
century, one which many people say was handed
down by the framers. But times change, and
the world and the U.S. has gotten much more
complex.
Economic concerns take up an increasingly
large part of our lives and many of them,
especially big macroeconomic policies require
big solutions. And for many Americans, but
certainly not all of them, the best solution
we have is government.
Thanks for watching. See you next time.
Crash Course Government and Politics is produced
in association with PBS Digital Studios.
Support for Crash Course: U.S. Government
comes from Voqal. Voqal supports nonprofits
that use technology and media to advance social
equity. Learn more about their mission and
initiatives at Voqal.org.
Crash Course was made with the help of all
these occupational safety and health hazards.
Thanks for watching.